[Musique]
occupe ses avocats ma grande jupe adam
tour non moi j'ai ma cousine qui habite
là c'est pour ça qu'on a pu emménager
d'abonnés tous les grains quartiers
crasseux peut-être que je ne croise les
dossiers alors
à la ronde il fait bon jour mais s'ils
bougent pas et c'était notre board
parlez-moi correctement c'est vrai que
je
commence à ce courrier écrit thomas
va cesser piétiné comme ça ou quoi on
apprend tout avec un mec
finissent à la réputation du direct
arrête attendait de compte
stoke est malade
de la honte là et ensuite tu me dis que
tu es désolé c'est ça
[Musique]
là quand ça se peut
et
ça je crois pas je comprends pas moi
votre génération vous vous irez coran
toutes les 100 minutes quand on arrive
en france pour chercher la liberté
est sûr qu'un jour tu me ramènes un beau
jeune homme
j'y crois bien géré cette hilarante
existe plus pour mon second
[Musique]
au
total